نعم حسن الغارات الاسرائيليه والقصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي لازال متواصلا على
مختلف المناطق في مدينه خانيونس وتحديدا
على المنطقه الجنوبيه والغربيه منها التي
تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي انسحبت قبل قليل من ساحه مستشفى
الامل بعد اقتحامه لنحو ساعتين على الاقل
وسط اطلاق نار كثيف من قبل الاليات
العسكريه وجنود جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ومنع الدخول او الخروج من هذا المستشفى
نتحدث في مدينه خان يونس حصيله هذا اليوم
وما وصل و تمكن من الوصول الى مستشفيات عن
14 شهيدا بينهم سبعه من الشهداء في مستشفى
الامل لوحدها من بين الشهداء السبعه سيده
وطفله لم تتجاوز الار يوما من عمرها
استشهدت بعد انقطاع الاكسجين عن هذا
المستشفى المحاصر لليوم العاشر على
التوالي الى جانب ايضا الوضع الانساني
والصحي الكارثي في مجمع ناصر الطبي في ظل
نقص حاد في المستلزمات الطبيه وايضا
المواد التمونيه وعدد قليل جدا من الاطباء
والممرضين الذين يعالجون المئات من الجرحى
الذين يصلون بطبيعه الحال عبر وسائل نقل
بدائيه او سيرا على الاقدام نتيجه
الاستهداف اسرائيلي المباشر والمتعمد
لسيارات الاسعاف وعدم السماح لها بالتحرك
خارج اسوار سواء مستشفى الامل او حتى
مستشفى ناصر هنا في مدينه رفح الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه قصفت منزلا من الصفيح
لعائله ابو شلوف قرب معبر رفح هذا المنزل
كان يؤوي نازحين من عائله النباهين ما ادى
الى ارتقاء امراه وطفلها بالاضافه الى
وصول عدد من الاصابات الى مستشفى ابو يوسف
النجار كما استهدفت الزوارق الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ساحل مدينه رفح هذا الساحل
التي الذي لجا اليه المئات من العائلات
التي نزحت مؤخرا الى المدينه ولم تجد
مكانا داخل هذه المدينه سواء في مراكز
الاواء او حتى في الساحات العامه نتحدث عن
مئات الالاف من النازحين داخل هذه المدينه
وسط ظروف انسانيه صعبه
ومحدود وكميات محدوده جدا من المساعدات
غذائيه وايضا من الرعايه الطبيه في دير
البلح في وسط القطاع ايضا الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه استهدفت صاله النخيل
في دير البلح وادت الى اصابه عدد من
النازحين نقلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
وفي بيت حنون قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي استهدف
مجموعه من المواطنين الى الشمال الغربي
الى الشمال الشرقي من من قطاع غزه ادى الى
ارتقاء امراه وايضا وصول عدد من الاصابات
الى مستشفى كمال عدوان في الشمال شكرا لك
من شرافي حدثنا من رفح